you two you hang around together a lot
off-camera
we do we like to we I mean most the time
we're at work but when we can we've been
over her house and she's been to a few
of my parties I like to throw parties
and what kind of parties do you throw
and why ha ha invited I would but I
didn't think you'd come
I mean why would you bomb you're not
gonna come are you talking about come if
I invited you to well why do you say
that what do you think I wouldn't come
to a party all right
I'll invite you we'll see we'll see what
happened it's not gonna happen is she's
saying that she's saying that on the air
just so you know how show business works
oh yeah no of course yeah
no invite I promise I'm gonna be outside
your window at the next one like a creep
and you better have your dance on cuz I
dance it's all about the dance at my
house cuz I don't like to talk I like to
dance
what kind of dance I do I do dances
about different occupations different
people's occupation oh that's just do a
dance about being a stewardess I do a
dance about being a gardener I do a
dance about you you just you can you
know that's what you mean you do a dance
about being a gardener your you I
picture all the other guests sitting in
silence you have to do it too well you
walk sure you're in the middle of the
room like raking is backing out yeah you
could do whatever I mean it's just it's
a fun thing to do I don't know why I
started doing that I don't I don't know
what's your favorite one that you do
stewardess is my stewardess yeah okay
can we see a little bit of the
stewardess mine okay I will do service
but I need some upbeat disco thats up to
those guys they play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you